I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I could go out and read one of
those diet books that was written by an
MD in a weekend like it was an easy read
for me I'd highlight a couple things act
like it was a textbook sort of
referenced the study look at the studies
they were referencing see if they made
sense to me but what I didn't find is it
between those and like the Pinterest
soup Cleanse diet that people look up to
lose ten pounds and you know Vita for a
vacation yeah there was nothing in the
middle that trusted people with the
science and gave them a little bit of
light structure to eat what they wanted
to eat everything I everything in that
space was sort of like along the lines
of you know really like allowing people
to trust their into intuitive eating
right well for me intuitive eating if I
have a doughnut my intuitive next meal
is a piece of pizza mm-hmm like and I
know on a biological level that
emotional eating yeah because my blood
Sugar's going up and crashing down and
all I'm craving is more carbohydrates
and starches and it's those highly
palatable foods that are there like
drugs there are first drugs growing up
you know for kids you see it they go to
a sleepover they come home they're
crazed and I remember feeling that way
so I wanted people to have that light
science but a little bit of structure so
they understood how to balance their
blood sugar how to eat an
anti-inflammatory diet you know how to
shut down hunger hormones and said
fighting not to eat right if it's the
craving that you're failing from ya got
the craving exactly and there's so much
so many people out there that are just
trying to white-knuckle will power their
way from meal to meal or they read one
of these diet books that inspires them
for a minute they take that PDF of like
what they can eat and what they can't
eat or they're doing something that is
unsustainable like the ketogenic diet I
talked about in 2014 an article for
birdie which is like a click media it's
like a website for beauty and health and
no one was talking about it but it was
in the research it was coming out in the
studies and I was seeing it but it's not
something that I think people can
sustain until they're 90 years old right
it's something that you could use as a
functional and
vention to ditch sugar cravings to
increase brain health to burn some fat
and feel good some kind of a recess yeah
but it but you have to look at it that
way and the thing is is people jump into
these things thinking that they're gonna
do it for the rest of their life and
then they fail and their confidence you
know hits the ground and they feel bad
about themselves because they can't you
know control what's on their fork
instead of thinking about their business
and what they can get back to the world
and their family and their all those
really all the things that really make
life worth living so I tried to really
answer what I saw was like a big black
hole in the marketplace which is like
how do I give you the tools to eat what
you love to understand a little bit of a
science to stay motivated because we're
motivated by information and then really
you know be able to live a flexible life
right so that's what I tried to do with
the book or just okay and with my
business yeah my clients yeah like it
isn't something rice you know I do
consultations I sit down with people we
have roles I mean there are people with
very strict rules and they have to be in
some type of like x-men suit or whatever
yeah and we have to get serious but when
it comes to you know finishing those
deadlines it really is about integrating
it into a lifestyle so that they're
confident eating clean going to dinner
with yeah friends needs to not be a diet
it needs to be a lifestyle it needs to
be something that is not temporary but
permanent apps and the permanence can
evolve but the permanence of taking care
of yourself and eating responsibly
drinking responsibly having the
emotional attachment to food with a with
a level of understanding that's one
thing that I feel like you know people
think of healthy eating and they think
it's a punishment I'm like you're
ridiculous you obviously have no idea
how I'm you don't realize but I made you
basically a vegan paleo dinner tonight
and you didn't even know it you know you
had no idea that was gluten-free had no
idea that was dairy for you no idea
right but so so many people don't don't
cook for themselves and they don't know
what's healthy or they just have this
negative association with food and
fitness like being punishments and I
just think that that emotional can
action or disconnection is so
detrimental to people because it's
somehow not a positive
[Music]